everybody just a quick note before we
get started this is Joshua fields
Millburn ryan and i recorded a live
version of ask the minimalists i think
this one was on facebook alive and Shawn
was kind enough to capture the audio
from this we wanted to go ahead and put
that in your feed because we felt good
about some of the questions and there
were some questions in here that rarely
get asked so we wanted to throw this
into your feet so we hope you enjoy that
also if you'd like to ask us some
questions in person we'll be hitting the
road a lot this year starting with
Boston and then some other cities after
that you can find all the details
tickets and sign up for our newsletter
to be notified of when we're coming to
your city over at the minimalists comm a
slash tour and each city Ryan and I will
give a talk about minimalism and we will
record a live version of our podcast
answering your questions and of course
afterward we will dish out a bunch of
free hugs
that's the minimalists comm a slash tour
to find your city alright I hope you
enjoyed this live version of ask the
minimalists
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without hey everyone it's Joshua
fields will burn I'm Ryan Nicodemus
welcome to a ask the minimalist Facebook
live session where we want to answer all
the awesome questions you have well we
do indeed so we are on Facebook live
right now our documentary just came out
next Netflix a few weeks ago is called
minimalism a documentary about the
important things if you haven't checked
it out you can check it out over there
on Netflix if you don't have Netflix you
can find it on iTunes or Google Play or
Amazon or Vimeo or wherever you find
your your documentaries these days we're
gonna answer a bunch of questions for
you Sean is over here podcast Sean he's
the producer for our podcast and
operational guru for the minimalists he
handles all things difficult for the
minimalists he's going to be throwing
out some random questions from you all
so feel free to start asking your
questions and don't worry if you if we
don't have an answer for your question
we brought an entire bag of answers so
we'll answer a random question if we
don't have an answer to your question so
go ahead and start asking and I think we
will start answering yes so we have any
questions yet if not I got plenty of
questions for Josh when are we coming to
your town never I'm just kidding
no we would love to come to your town
man I wish we could visit every single
city in every single part of the world I
will say that we are planning to come to
some random cities this year and if you
go to the minimalist calm / tour you
could certainly see our tour schedule
there or if you go to the minimalist
calm and put your email address in there
and sign up for our newsletter you will
certainly be made aware through that
newsletter of when
we will be touring and where we will be
I hope we can see you soon
yeah we've been to a bunch of cities
over the last what we started doing
tours back in 2011 yeah our very first
book came out was called minimalism live
a meaningful life Ryan and I wrote about
getting rid of the excess stuff in our
life and uncovering these these five
values health relationships passion
gross contribution and we hit the road
with that book and it was an amazing
experience for me because we didn't have
much of a readership at that time and so
our very first tour stop was in st.
Petersburg Florida which is really where
minimalism kind of started for me it's
where my mother lived when she passed
away and and and when she when that
happened I started questioning a bunch
of different things in my life and and
so I had to go down there and deal with
a lot of her possessions and it was my
first my first leap into letting go
especially of letting go of sentimental
items and so we went down there for this
tour stopped in November of 2011 and
eight people showed up and I was
completely blown away Josh the two of us
don't count hey i Ryan I I resent that
comment I think you do count that was a
great stop in that's where we that's
where we were like we finally discovered
like you know what we're huggers now yes
we're not gonna shake hands anymore huh
yeah yeah and so so if you've been able
to make out too
many of I mean we've done over a several
hundred tour stops at this point and we
will certainly do a lot more and if you
like we will certainly dish out hugs
they are free and transferable so make
sure you grab one next time we're on
tour if you sign up for that email list
you will be the first to know the crowds
have grown a bit since then a little bit
we've been fortunate enough to be at
those the small events where we've had
literally two people show up in
Knoxville Tennessee we had two people
show up in Salt Lake City and you know
now it's hundreds or in some cases even
thousands of people that show up at the
end of our tour 2014 we did 100 cities
or in was it eight countries 119 events
and in Sydney Australia we had something
like 1400 people who showed up there and
what we've learned throughout this whole
journey is there was
nothing that was like a viral moment for
us it just slowly and incrementally grew
because when you get value from
something you tend to share it with your
friends and family and so when you learn
about this minimalist lifestyle when you
learn about about letting go and you
find some value in it you tend to share
it with the people you care about in
hopes that they get the same amount of
value from that as well and so I think
it's the reason that the documentary is
done fairly well recently a lot of
people were sharing that with their
friends and family and we're just
grateful that you're willing to give up
your two most precious resources with us
so it's your time and your attention
we're grateful that our message is is
serving some purpose and and allowing us
to contribute in a meaningful way
all right showing what else we got man
does minimalism have to be all-in or can
it be a gradual transition I don't know
I mean what do you think we should just
start telling people to get a dumpster
and throw everything away right yeah
that's that's that's real minimalism
there well in retrospect that's kind of
what I wish I would have done right like
like not literally throwing my stuff out
but I wish I would have gotten rid of
90% of my stuff and a more
environmentally friendly way than just
throwing it out I would I wish what I
would have done was identified very
quickly what adds value to my life in
fact so so Ryan and I had different
stories when we jumped into it yeah I
let go of one thing a day for 30 days to
get some momentum that I needed and then
that that snowball started to take off
and so it was very gradual for me but at
the end of eight months I realized I've
gotten rid of about 90% of my
possessions now the average American
household has 300 thousand items in it
so think about the math there 300,000
items I probably had more than that if
I'm being honest with myself and if I
get rid of what 90% of that stuff I
still have 30,000 items left so you
don't walk into my house today usually
and say oh my god these people are
minimalist you walk in and say wow this
is family is really tidy and it's
because we don't know much but
everything that we do owned serves a
purpose or brings us joy but it took me
a lot really long time to get there
and I wish I would have done basically
what you did Ryan and it just sort of
box up all my junk
yeah and you know I'm still not done
being a minimalist so you know I think
it is always going to be a gradual
process I mean unless you do get a
dumpster and throw everything out well
you'll probably be miserable if you do
that so you know I would I would say yes
minimalism is always gonna be this
gradual process I wish god I wish I had
this like perfect list of you know
hundred things or 200 things like hey
you know me and Mariah we've decided
that here are the most the most
important 200 things in our lives and if
you and your partner if you decide to
bring these 200 things in your life and
that's it this will make you perfectly
happy but like that's just that's just
not how it works the key to happiness
how great would that be
oh man just here yeah here the hundred
items you're supposed to own and then
here's the Magic Bullet answer man
that'd be so nice but the truth is the
things that value to my life may not add
value to Ryan's Ryan has a snowboard and
he uses it all the time
if I own the snowboard I would be a
waste of space a waste of money and and
and also would take up this sort of
mental clutter as well because I own
this thing why am i storing it while it
wouldn't make sense but for Ryan it
certainly makes sense because it is a
tool that improves his life and so the
things that I valued in my life may not
add value yours and vice-versa and
here's the other cool thing I'm 35 years
old now and the things that I I get a
lot of joy from today are gonna be
different the things that I need today
are different and so like Ryan said it's
not a journey that you would you you get
there once you get to the horizon
there's always gonna be another horizon
yeah I would even throw a warning out
there if you ever feel like you're
getting to the end of your minimalist
journey that's probably a cue for you to
really start making sure that you're
keeping up those habits that you
instilled because it's so often that I
hear people say oh man I decluttered I
got rid of so much stuff I really had
some good habits and then you know I
kind of let that stuff creep back in
because I thought I was done and yeah
just to reiterate you're never done with
with minimalism it is a constant journey
and yet good luck on your journey what
else we got Sean okay if you buy each of
your family member three copies of our
book
it'll be you know it'll fix them
permanently Josh now what each member
has to have three coffee exactly of each
book of each book so nine books told
right you've written three books you
know well they're all basically the same
book we just put different covers on
right right no so so Ryan and I wrote a
a why to book a what to book and a how
to book we kind of go through the
details you go to the minimalists comm
slash the number three all spelled out
it's called don't collect all three but
that's really the purpose like our books
are just experiences they're meant to be
passed on and then minimized it after
you're done with it and I wish there was
another answer here that was simple like
well here's the thing that you can do to
get your entire family on board but
here's another way to think about it how
do you get your entire family to go play
hockey it's gonna be really difficult to
go get your whole family to go play
hockey but if you want if you truly want
them to do it the best way to do it
instead of dragging them all out onto
the ice and starting to like nail cleats
on it's not cleats is skates why are
they worried why is your family wearing
cleats on the ice why would you do that
to your family so you're not going to no
cleats to their feet or skates to their
feet or buy them a bunch of hockey books
oh my goodness no what you're gonna do
is show them how much fun you have the
benefits you're experiencing from from
hockey and maybe some of them may enjoy
it somewhat a similar to how you have
have decided to enjoy hockey now the
nice thing about this is about
minimalism is it's more applicable than
hockey is obviously because the benefits
are greater with something like
minimalism because they're different for
all of us for me when I first embraced
minimalism it was because I was in so
much that I had six figures worth of
debt and I needed to to get rid of that
and so I realized one of the benefits
for me was letting go the stuff allow me
to refocus my priorities and maybe not
be as tied to this income long term if I
was able to pay off my debt and live a
more meaningful life even with less
money and that was okay for me to be
able to do that and so letting go the
stuff meant I could pay off the debt
but for other people that they may not
have a problem with that and especially
for kids they don't have a problem with
that
you know what that is every time I try
to explain to Ella like yet to pay for
something she hey Josh I want to go hear
that so well who's gonna pay for it it's
just I don't know yeah and so debt isn't
a big a big factor for her so so the
question that really resonates with a
lot of people is how might your life be
better with less you're gonna have to
ask your question to your family how
might your life be better with less and
help them identify what what in their
life could improve by having fewer
attachments to material possessions
that's a good point man like if they
don't see the reason why they want to
start minimizing like they're never
gonna minimize right I mean it's it's
like someone who plays video games all
day long if they don't see a problem
with it then there's no way that you're
gonna get that person to stop playing
video games exactly yeah and so so
identifying those those benefits are
great great first step and then once you
get on the same page the best way to do
that is figure what are the common
benefits because if that's a problem for
you and then and then shopping is taking
up too much time for someone else so
they're regaining control of their time
someone else are they regain control of
their creativity maybe figure out what
the common benefits are for the entire
family and then start to focus on those
using the same language and I think
they're the reason we've we've written a
few books and put a documentary out
there is we want to give people the the
vernacular we want to give you the
common language that you can use to
simplify your lives together and so I
think there's a good place to start you
can go to your local library and find
any of our any of our three books I
would certainly recommend with starting
with book on everything that remains
that that's the why to book it's a
journey of the last five years of our
lives that we went from these
suit-and-tie corporate guides to
becoming the minimalists and then we
wrote a book called minimalism live a
meaningful life it uncovers the five
values living more intentionally and
then we wrote an essay collection called
essential and that book has 150 essays
about twelve different topics everything
from
finances to mindfulness to decluttering
to priorities and success and sort of
everything in between and so I think if
you go down that path it'll help you
identify what's the language we're gonna
use to start working on this together
and then last but not least work hard to
understand the people in your family
just because you're getting not getting
value from something does
mean that they won't and so you have to
not just tolerate them but work on a
path toward acceptance and respect and
ultimately appreciation of other
people's values and joy and beliefs yeah
and you know I would just add if you
have someone in your household whose
maximalism is like encroaching on your
life and it's someone in your life who
who loves you and wants you to be happy
it's perfectly appropriate to go to that
person and ask for support it doesn't
mean that they have to have a packing
party or that they have to get another
DVD collection but but it does mean that
they do need to at least support you the
way that you're trying to support them
another idea - that I've seen working a
lot of households is just putting a
donation box out and and maybe in the
living room somewhere where it's it's
always in front of the family
I know I've seen families do this where
the the the other family members were
not on board they didn't want to give up
anything but then when they saw that
donation box it made them think like wow
maybe I can contribute to someone else
in a meaningful way or give someone
something who that I'm not using and I'm
not finding value and it made me that
person will find value in it kids love
to donate like this is this is this is a
great way to get kids involved so
there's a couple more tips for you yeah
good luck for end-of-life planning well
I wrote an essay about this I'll pull it
up real quick
give me a second here and I'll let Ryan
pontificate yes no end-of-life planning
I don't know if they're talking about
retirement or if they're talking about a
funeral okay so we're talking about
funeral arrangements I mean first off
and this is just my personal opinion so
like take this with a grain of salt and
you know this is not like me preaching
that everyone else should have this this
attitude but my opinion is why would I
spend thousands of dollars on a box to
put myself in a ground like that doesn't
make it to me like that doesn't make any
sense like I would just I would either
donate my body to science and which my
grandfather totally did or I could
just get cremated I actually probably
donated my body to size this would be
the most value-adding way or vote most
value anything I could do with my death
but spending thousands of dollars on on
a casket and in the funeral and Rangers
I mean certainly you know if people want
to have a memorial or something I mean
that's totally appropriate but spending
the extra thousands of dollars on the
casket and then getting buried in the
ground to me seems kind of silly man hmm
yeah well I agree with you so in fact in
my my will and I have a little wall card
in my wallet as well so a few things one
is I have a do not reset do not
resuscitate and basically I don't want
to be given anything besides painkillers
at end of life so my will it talks about
I want to donate my organs to science
and then whatever is left and they just
be cremated right because you once I'm
gone even if I my body still there I
believe that that I am I'm gone right
but let's talk about a death preparing
for death so here's an essay at the
minimalists comm slash death and it's
called scared to death of death the
important things that we postpone so I
saw some of my will but let me just read
this to you real quick I think it'll
it'll provide some direction for that
question
no one wants to discuss death and yet
we're all going to die obviously which
makes for an irksome paradox what's
worse is we often refuse to discuss
important topics surrounding deaths such
as burial plans cremation living wills
and the like the younger we are the more
we pretend the inevitable isn't
inevitable and so we live our daily
lives with these worries in the back of
our minds uncertain of what will happen
if we get sick if we die and
unexpectedly if we become unconscious
and can no longer make decisions for
ourselves well that could never happen
to me we think knowing full well it
could and it might young or old
were all one brief moment away from a
disaster we needn't be afraid though
just prepared I wasn't prepared for many
many years recently though I took
worried by that I took worried by the
hand and
the fact that at anytime I'm a moment
away from death so I decided to plan
accordingly by obtaining the following
documents so the first thing I got was a
living will living will which is also
known as an advanced care advanced
health care directive or advanced
medical directive is a legal document
that provides your family doctors and
caregivers with information about what
life saving measures you wish to be
taken should there come a time when you
are unable to communicate your wishes
the next document is a last will and
testament a last will and testament will
is a legal document that dictates what
happens to your estate once you pass
away if you have a complicated estate
it's best to have an attorney obviously
help you with you with writing your your
last will and testament so you can
ensure your estate is settled
appropriately if your situation is
relatively straightforward like mine you
can draft your own last will and
testament which will save you on
attorneys fees I'd it's actually
something between will talk about a
second here it's best to learn about the
components of a last will and testament
and how you can ensure that yours is
legally viable and that was important
for me the next thing I did was a power
of attorney as an independent adult it
is important that for you to have a will
but you must also consider your power of
attorney
this document legally allows a person to
you select to be in charge your
financial matters such as conducting
bank transactions investing money so
that person for me is Ryan property
matters such as management of property
and other legal situations such as
operating a small business a power of
attorney is not only used in cases of
disability and illness but is also in
cases where you can but also in cases
where you can't be somewhere to sign a
legal document so my power of attorney
is is just upon sort of my if I'm if I'm
unable to sign to sign a document last
thing I got here is organ donor
so I wrote a whole essay about that I
won't bother reading it to you but I
would encourage you to be an organ donor
and because if you can literally save
other people's lives even in your own
death although I want to live for a long
time
my deathbed ducks are now in a row even
better I'm free of the worry regarding
those plans there are other documents
and considerations to consider but the
four listed above are a great start
toward calm waters and a coal mine
personally I used a service called
LegalZoom and I don't have any stake in
the company or Sun advertising or
anything that's just who I use
personally for some of the above
documents super affordable yeah yeah I
mean they mean to get all of those
documents it's like what 50 bucks maybe
it was over 100 but yeah we still go to
an attorney it's gonna cost you over
$1000 yeah and so I found that for me
just thats it that it's a relief to feel
prepared for that right and so I have a
last will and I've actually used them
for other documents too we use them for
our business operating agreement we use
it to form an LLC in the past so I've
used it for four different stuff in the
past and you know it's up to you you
know what's your comfort level do you
want someone else to be determining
what's going to happen even with the the
$800 that's in your checking account or
whatever because it's gonna be really
difficult even if someone has access to
that it's gonna be difficult to prove to
to the government and someone's going to
decide for you you might as well be the
one who decides for yourself so you can
check that out the minimalists comm
slash death yeah that is a good question
thank you very much what else we got
Sean so Sean Sean just gave us a
question about what do you do when you
have an item and you feel like you've
spent so much money on that you know a
couple years ago why would you why would
you get rid of something you spent so
much money on you know I had this
experience with the packing party when I
was going through that 80% of stuff that
was still left in boxes I had all these
old cell phones now keep in mind first
off I worked at the telecommunications
company so I had access to phones it's
not like I needed to hold on to these
old cellphones but that's why I held on
to moves with that mentality of man this
phone well this this blackberry Goodman
that get a drawer full
obsolete black obsolete blackberries but
you know what though
coming from that world I know that the
company I worked for you know when they
had a retail price of for $99.99 retail
that's what the company paid for maybe
they paid for $89.99 for it and marked
it up ten bucks but I know that that
phone was worth hundreds of dollars well
you know two or three years later like I
really had to be honest with myself that
phone is I'm never gonna get hundreds of
dollars out of it in fact I'd be lucky
to get even ten bucks out of it right
and I started to have to I started
having to look at things a sunk cost and
I think you know another way to look at
it too is opportunity cost if you hold
on to an item that is making you feel
weighed down that you are feeling
stressed out about and you decide to
hold on to it well the freedom that
that's space clearing in your mind
that's the opportunity cost you're
giving that up whereas if you are giving
up that phone you are gaining that that
space in your mind you're gaining less
clutter and the opportunity cost is that
sunk cost that you're never gonna get
back anyway yeah I totally agree so the
the sunk cost fallacy is real and the
way that I was able to get over it is
something that it's a rule that we
implemented a long time ago but it's
helped me out a lot it's called the
just-in-case rule you might also know it
as the 20/20 rule and I found that many
of those things hold on to and
especially the things that were
supposedly more expensive like a
Blackberry or a piece of furniture that
I never used or whatever the these were
things hold on to just in case I needed
them someday and some non-existent
hypothetical future and what I learned
is that these three words just in case
they disempowered me they forced me to
continue to hold on to these things
because I thought I might need them
someday but the truth is that nearly a
hundred percent of the just in case
items that we hold on to we're never
going to use again and so what I
realized is that I can do myself
permission to let go of these just in
case items and anything I needed to
replace just in case I could replace for
less than twenty dollars in less than 20
minutes from wherever I am and that rule
is held up for me and Ryan 100% of the
time were the last five years since we
implemented that rule and between the
two of us we have we've had to use that
rule five times
and that the and so yeah it's gonna cost
you 20 bucks times five
there's hundred dollars half of that's
fifty so its cost me fifty dollars in
five years ten dollars a year it's
pretty cheap insurance yeah it to to let
go of literally tens of thousands of
items are in the way that I would need a
bigger space or a storage locker or
something else to to hold on to these
things they're gonna cost me a lot more
even holding on to those things not just
the price but it's gonna cost me a lot
more mentally emotionally physically
holding on to those those physical items
especially if you move and you have to
love all those just in case items around
but I letting go of those also you're
gonna add value to someone else's life
because you're not getting value from it
anymore but let's be honest right if you
who'd gotten rid of those blackberries
two years earlier someone who didn't
have a phone will always have the
opportunity to use that somewhere to the
point and we had we had donation
programs that you know somewhere someone
somewhere would be able to use that as
opposed to just sitting in a drawer
until it becomes a useless piece of junk
no Shawn let's do one more question here
make it a good one a really good one
that's a good good question so the
question was if if everyone stopped
buying stuff and became a minimalist it
would crash the economy oh my god
they're right it would crash the economy
that is a that is a very very true
statement if everyone stopped buying
everything it would crash the economy
but guess what
when everyone buys stuff and buys too
much that also crashes the economy as we
saw in 2008 when we take out too much
debt when we take out too many loans
when we consume too our hardest content
and more the economy crashes as well and
I like to think that minimalism kind of
brings a balance between those two
extremes because minimalism is not about
consuming it's it's not about not
consuming it's not about just giving up
your purchasing power and going off in
the middle of the woods and shredding
your identification and never talking to
the government I mean that is maybe for
some people minimalism but that's not
that's not Josh and eyes
way that we live our lives and that's
not how we're encouraging other people
to live their lives what we really talk
against is that compulsory consumption
that that impulse of consumption buying
things to fill this void that will never
be filled with stuff I think all this is
a perfect way to end it because this
question is an important one for a few
things I'll say first office no I don't
think everyone's gonna jump up and
become a minimalist then that's not what
we're trying to do we're not trying
trying to convert everyone to minimalism
Josh I don't think we can't convert
people by definition exactly there's
nothing to convert to I can't baptize
you in minimalism I don't have a
certificate for you wait a minute I
think you're up we could sir charge it
for baptisms and certificates it was
like a little dropper of water no so I'm
gonna read this to you it's an essay
that I wrote over at the minimalists
actually both of us wrote it's called
stimulate the economy like a minimalist
if everyone immediately stops spending
their money our economy would crash this
goes without saying consequently one of
the biggest supposed arguments many
people have against minimalism is that
if everyone became a minimalist then
we'd all be doomed the financial system
as it stands today would collapse and no
longer would we have the wealth
necessary to purchase cheap plastic crap
from Walmart there are several problems
with this point of view some obvious
some a bit more abstruse first no
informed person would argue that we
should stop spending money or that we
must stop consuming consumption is not
the problem
compulsory consumption is the problem
consumerism is compulsory vapid
pernicious impulsive unfocused misguided
worst of all it is seductive consumerism
shiny facade promises more than it can
possibly deliver because love happiness
contentment and satisfaction are all
internal feelings that cannot be
commodified and the truth is that once
our basic needs are met the acquisition
of trinkets does little for our lifelong
well-being using consumerism to
stimulate the economy is like fixing a
cracked
with a hammer it only worsens the
problem yes trade is an important part
of any society circumventing consumerism
however doesn't a doesn't imply that
minimalist sidestep commerce rather
minimalism is predicated on
intentionality which means we spend our
money more deliberately minimalist
invests in experiences over possessions
travel in the concerts vacations
community theater etc we can all spend
money without acquiring new material
possessions minimalist buy new
possessions carefully to do so we must
ask better questions like will this
thing add value to my life take a drink
that's the drinking game for anyone any
time we save add value on our podcast
which by the way we'd have a bunch of
new podcast episodes come out in the
last week or two creativity and letting
go and parenting and a bunch of other
stuff so if you haven't checked it out
yet you can just go to our iTunes feed
iTunes comm slash the minimalists anyway
back to the text here minimalist support
local businesses local indie shops tend
to be less motivated by profit sure they
need to make money to keep the lights on
and there's nothing wrong with that but
earning a buck usually isn't the primary
concern of the local bookstore
restaurateur or bike shop they are in
business because they are passionate
about the product about their product or
service and they want to share that
passion with their patrons passion
begets greater quality and better
service which makes the money they earn
well-deserved ultimately minimalists
aren't interested in quote stimulating
the economy stimulation is ephemeral
we'd rather improve our economy's
long-term health by making better
individual decisions about consumption
getting involved in our community and
supporting local businesses who care if
more people do this will build a
stronger community one that's predicated
on personal responsibility and community
interaction not a false sense of urgency
and the mindless stockpiling of junk we
never need it in the first place
all right so I think that's a good place
to end it thanks for spending this time
with us today
joining us on Facebook live if you
haven't yet you want to check out our
documentary you can on Netflix it's
called minimalism a documentary about
the important things and we just
recorded our 50th episode a few moments
ago for our podcast so we've done a year
of podcasting of the minimalist podcast
which you can check out over at the
minimalists com and as always if you
leave here with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a gray oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tear your eyes or two
[Music]
you
[Music]